.
Ach, wissenschaftliche Studien.
Und so viele Produkte im Netz,
deren heilbringende Wirkung
natürlich mit wissenschaftlichen
Studien belegt ist.
Nicht zu vergessen
so Sachen wie die Impflüge.
Brought to you
by wissenschaftliche Studie.
Die Frage ist doch jetzt, was kann
ich als Laie, als Fachfremde tun,
um wissenschaftliche Studien
besser zu verstehen?
Holt euch 'nen Tee,
Freunde der Sonne, und setzt euch,
denn die Antwort
wird euch nicht gefallen.
* Titelmusik *
Also noch mal,
was können Laien tun,
um wissenschaftliche Studien
besser zu verstehen?
Die Antwort ist: nichts. Was?
Also zumindest nicht viel.
Passt auf, wissenschaftliche
Informationen findet man entweder
in Fachbüchern,
so wie sie in Uni-Bibs stehen,
v.a.die etablierten
wissenschaftlichen Informationen.
Oder in wissenschaftlichen
Veröffentlichungen,
man sagt auch Paper,
da findet man v.a.auch
die neuen Forschungsergebnisse,
aktuelle Wissenschaft, das ist
ja das, was uns als Gesellschaft
oft am meisten interessiert,
sei es der Klimawandel
oder Aktivkohle-Zahnpasta.
Wenn ihr in ein Paper schaut,
werdet ihr oft feststellen:
Was??
Aber nicht, weil ihr dumm seid,
sondern weil Paper nun mal nicht
für die allgemeine Öffentlichkeit
geschrieben sind.
Paper sind dazu da,
dass sich Expertinnen und Experten
auf höchstem fachlichen Niveau
und im Detail austauschen können.
Fachsprache ist super für Experten,
weil die sich so sehr detailliert
und spezifisch ausdrücken können.
Fachsprache ist aber
eine Fremdsprache für Laien.
Aber Mai. - Ja? - Willst du uns
eigentlich verarschen? - Nein...?
Du sprichst ständig von Studien,
also du verstehst sie,
aber wir sind zu blöd dafür?
Nanana!
Hier geht's ja nicht
um Intelligenz oder so,
hier geht's um Ausbildung
und um Zeit.
Ich hab z.B.in der Chemie
eine Doktorarbeit gemacht.
Und wie alle Doktoranden
musste ich mir über Jahre
viel neues Wissen aneignen, ich
musste aktuelle Forschung verfolgen
und dazu musste ich
ganz viele Paper lesen,
auch aus Bereichen, von denen ich
davor keine Ahnung hatte.
Das war am Anfang sehr anstrengend,
das ist für alle anstrengend.
Aber mit der Zeit checkt man
die Sachen irgendwann schneller.
Trotzdem ist es nicht so,
dass ich mir ein Paper durchlese
und 10 Min.später denke:
Klar, logisch.
Aber dafür bin ich Vollzeit-
Wissenschaftsjournalistin.
So hab ich auch voll Zeit,
mich in wissenschaftliche Paper
reinzufuchsen.
Ich besorge mir auch Fachbücher
und ich spreche mit Experten,
bis ich alles verstanden habe
und dieses Wissen kann ich dann
hier an euch weitergeben.
Aber heißt das jetzt,
ihr müsst mir blind vertrauen?
Hierzu ein guter Kommentar:
Tja, Pattipuh x3,
du ahnst es schon:
Du kannst es nicht wissen.
Ich verlinke
meine wissenschaftlichen Quellen
in der Videobeschreibung.
Aber ihr habt wahrscheinlich
nicht die Kapazitäten,
diese Quellen alle zu überprüfen.
Es sei denn, sie sind zufällig
aus eurem Fachbereich.
Oder ihr habt
nichts anderes zu tun im Leben.
Übrigens, selbst wenn ihr meiner
Sorgfalt und Kompetenz vertraut,
vielen Dank, solltet ihr
trotzdem nicht ausschließen,
dass ich auch mal Fehler mache.
Seid also immer kritisch, habt eine
gesunde Skepsis, auch mir gegenüber,
aber seid auch dankbar
für Wissenschaftsjournalismus.
Wir brauchen
guten Wissenschaftsjournalismus,
denn nur so bleibt Forschung
kein elitäres Expertengeheimnis,
das hinter Fachsprache
versteckt ist,
sondern wird verständlich übersetzt.
Aber ich z.B.kann jetzt jede Woche
ein Video machen.
Das ist ja schon mal gut.
Zum Glück hab ich
noch viele tolle Kollegen,
ich kann jetzt wenige
von vielen guten nennen,
z.B.unsere funk-Homies
von kurzgesagt
oder auch meine Kollegen bei Quarks
oder das Kollektiv der RiffReporter,
die übrigens auch dieses Jahr den
Grimme Online Award gewonnen haben.
Aber alle Wissenschaftsjournalisten
dieser Welt kommen nicht an
gegen die Massen von Scharlatanen,
Abzockern, Populisten,
die wissenschaftliche Studien
missbrauchen für ihre Behauptungen,
die sie damit untermauern,
weil sie genau wissen,
dass Laien das gar nicht
so genau nachvollziehen können.
Ja, und jetzt?
Ich hätte da einen Vorschlag.
Stellt euch vor,
zu jedem wissenschaftlichen Paper
gäbe es eine allgemein
verständliche Zusammenfassung
der wichtigsten Ergebnisse,
eine Erklärung der Methoden
und eine Einordnung,
inwieweit diese Ergebnisse
praxisrelevant sind.
Inwieweit die Einfluss auf unser
alltägliches Leben haben oder nicht.
Stellt euch vor, wann immer jemand
eine wilde Behauptung aufstellt
und dazu eine Studie verlinkt,
könntet ihr euch
diese Übersetzung durchlesen
und euch selbst aufklären.
Wäre das nicht saugeil?
Joah, also saugeil
ist vielleicht etwas übertrieben.
Es wäre saugeil.
Der Knackpunkt ist aber,
wer schreibt diese Texte?
Eigentlich können das nur
die Forscher
und Wissenschaftler selbst.
Nur bis man seine komplizierte
Arbeit in einen verständlichen,
aber dennoch korrekten Text
übersetzt hat,
vergeht sehr viel Zeit
und Arbeit und Kopfzerbrechen.
Gleichzeitig gibt es
für Wissenschaftler keinen Anreiz,
Zeit und Arbeit in eine öffentliche
Kommunikation zu stecken,
denn es wird nicht belohnt.
Es gibt erste Anreize,
inzwischen kann man nicht nur
Forschungsgelder beantragen,
sondern immer öfter
auch Kommunikationsgelder.
Aber das reicht nicht,
man sollte es nicht nur ermöglichen,
man sollte es nicht nur belohnen,
man sollte es verlangen.
Erzwingen. Stellt euch vor,
in der Schule gäbe es
keine mündlichen Noten.
Würdet ihr euch dann noch
im Unterricht beteiligen
oder hättet ihr es getan? Eben.
Klar, nur weil man was machen muss,
macht man's nicht automatisch gut,
aber man kann es lernen.
Beispiel: Wissenschaftler
können relativ gut Englisch.
Denn sie müssen's können.
Denn die Paper sind auf Englisch,
Fachtagungen
sind in der Regel international
und auch im Labor
sind meist Leute aus aller Welt.
Man muss halt Englisch können.
Bevor ihr jetzt
z.B.Chemie studieren wolltet,
aber jetzt denkt,
scheiße, ich kann kein Englisch:
In meinem Semester hatten viele
eine schlechtere Note in Englisch.
Aber wenn man muss,
lernt man's einfach.
Ich kenne niemanden, bei dem es
am Englisch gescheitert ist.
Und Laiensprache ist auch nur eine
Fremdsprache, die man lernen kann.
Aber wie genau
zwingt man jetzt die Leute dazu?
Das, Freunde der Sonne,
ist genau die Frage,
die wir uns unbedingt stellen müssen
und am besten beantworten müssen:
Wie können wir verständliche Wissen-
schaft für alle zur Pflicht machen?
Eine Idee wäre,
das über die Verlage zu lösen,
also die Verlage,
die diese Paper publizieren,
könnten zu jedem
wissenschaftlichen Manuskript
auch eine allgemein verständliche
Version verlangen.
Nur das bedeutet auch, dass sie
mehr redaktionelle Arbeit hätten,
also auch da ist kein Anreiz.
Deswegen muss der Anreiz
aus der Politik kommen
und der Druck
aus der Öffentlichkeit.
Leute, in einer Zeit,
in der Fakten und Meinungen
immer öfter gleichgesetzt werden,
müssen wir uns alle einig sein,
dass Wissenschaft und Forschung
allgemein verständlich sein muss.
Und wir zahlen
die Forschung schließlich.
Forschung wird meistens
aus Steuergeldern finanziert.
Da muss man doch verlangen können,
dass Forschung nicht nur
wissenschaftliche Paper produziert,
sondern auch
eine öffentliche Version davon.
Ich hab noch keine konkreten Ideen,
wie man das in die Praxis umsetzt,
vielleicht fällt euch was ein,
aber ich dachte,
ich mach mit diesem Video den Anfang
und lenke die öffentliche
Aufmerksamkeit auf dieses Thema.
Wenn ihr helfen wollt
bei der Aufmerksamkeit,
teilt dieses Video gerne unter
dem Hashtag #wissenschaftfüralle.
Wir sehen uns in der Endcard.
Falls ihr mir bei Social Media
folgt, habt ihr evtl.mitbekommen,
dass ich bei der Fernseh-
wissenssendung Quarks
die Nachfolge von Rangar Yogeshwar
antrete. No pressure.
Nächstes Jahr werde ich also
recht oft bei Quarks zu sehen sein.
Aber keine Sorge,
maiLab läuft genauso weiter.
Würd ich auch für nichts
auf dieser Welt hergeben.
Eine Sache möchte ich ausprobieren,
und zwar würde ich gerne
unseren Upload-Tag
von Donnerstag auf Montag verlegen,
einfach weil das besser mit Quarks
in meinen neuen Wochenplan passt.
Ich meine, gibt's
einen besseren Start in die Woche?
Ich weiß, Montag, 6.30 Uhr,
das ist sehr... streberisch.
Aber irgendwie passt es zu uns,
findet ihr nicht?
Ich würde es gerne mal testen,
d.h.nächste Woche kommt das Video
nicht Donnerstag,
sondern an dem Montag danach.
Wir sehen uns also
erst in 1,5 Wochen.
Aber das Warten lohnt sich,
denn Saadet war mal wieder am Start.
Mehr verrate ich nicht,
bis dann, bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von funk (2018)